et depuis 2010 est il est danseur au
ballet de lyon dans notre chère ville
messieurs dames nous accueillons avaro
d'où le lait heureusement que m'ont
appelé en tant que danseur plutôt coup
pour mes prestations allant française
donc
quand je que je pense en fait ou
concepts perfection je pense à quelque
chose de fini d'absolu quelque chose que
am tous les chefs ou les qualités
attendues donc chimérique idéal tout ça
pour dire que les faits le concept de
perfection c'est étrange cette étrange
et au concept de l'art et de la danse
art éphémère l'art au delà d'être en
fonction de l'espèce humaine
c'est aussi la manifestation des
possibilités infinies et diverses
j'ai commencé la danse le ballet à l'âge
de 11 ans je suis danseur professionnel
de formation classique qui danse dans
une compagnie de ballet d'inspiration
contemporaine
à 18 ans je intégré dans un compagnie de
ballet et depuis 12 ans je m'entraîne
entre 6 heures et 8 heures par jour cinq
et six jours par semaine en donnons en
moyen de 40 spectacles par saison
c'est à dire déjà 400 spectacles
en douze ans pensez vous que dans tous
ses spectacles il ya eu un spectacle
parfait pas du tout j'ai toujours
entendu par mes profs de danse pendant
ma formation de ballet du rhin à cette
fille ce garçon ils ont le physique
parfait pour la danse
que veut-il dire dans le contexte du
ballet c'est de posséder tous les
qualités athlétiques et physiques
selon en colonne esthétique codifiée par
la danse classique c'est-à-dire
proportions
mobilité artistes mobilité articulaire
[Musique]
souplesse ou scolaire
coordination
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que ça moi je
réponds qu'est ce que ça veut dire tout
ça bon d'abord n'a pas de physique
parfait alors on peut voir un physique
correcte pas parfait on va toujours
avoir quelqu'un de plus souple plus
proportionnés plus voilà plus mobile
plus mobile est en tout cas n'est pas du
tout un canon esthétique fonctionnel et
defacto physique parfait ne fait pas un
bon danseur c'est aussi dans un autre
contexte conduisent le concept de
perfection c'est plutôt dans le contexte
d'exécution donc mendoza performance on
dépense tellement de deux heures du jour
pour maîtriser une pièce qu graphique ou
un balai en espérons toujours de donner
le mieux possible en performance
parfaite
oui mais c'est impossible
ça reste toujours un idéal regardez
j'avais écouté une première version
départ
[Applaudissements]
aïe je soufflais oh la la
hockey le gardien deuxième fois je vais
régler écouter les mêmes pas une
deuxième fois
[Applaudissements]
donc avait vu plus une exécution
parfaite
moi en tant que danseur non donc oui non
non non peut-être la deuxième fois
c'était un petit peu mieux
j'ai peu roulé un peu plus mais
justement parce que pour moi c'était un
peu plus facile comme je venais juste de
faire une première version avant mais
c'était moins fraîches et moi soupire le
nom peut-être que vous venez de le voir
une deuxième fois
en tout cas j'étais dans tous les cas
soumis à des facteurs facteurs internes
humaine universelle mais le stress des
douleurs musculaires d'aujourd'hui est
un autre facteur externe
regardez cette scène et c'est tapis que
je suis en fait là d une fois n'était
pas là mais c'est aujourd'hui la et donc
n'est pas du tout fait pour pour
présence et de sole et dur ça glisse pas
mais bon tant qu'on peut dire que chaque
performance était unique relativement et
à chaque fois une nouvelle expérience
mais pas on porte une exécution parfaite
ne fait pas un bon artiste c'est un
autre facteur
le troisième qui se montre qui
intervient dans un performance c'est le
facteur que moi j'appelle interprétation
artistique
tous les artistes interprétation manière
que ce soit une pièce de répertoire que
aux nouvelles créations
mais prenons un exemple un musicien
déjà en position est un petit peu plus
limité dans son interprétation
artistique vu qu'il doit suivre une
partition
le danseur en revanche un peu plus
d'interprétation liberté
d'interprétation sur simple de faire ses
choix sur scène et de rats présenter à
chaque représentation
ses propriétés et qualité un bon danseur
c'est évident qu'il doit aussi
concrétiser l'idée qu'au graphique
holiday duke au graff jusqu'au bout mais
même si la danse classique moderne post
moderne a quand même créé des codes
assez des règles des codes codifié dans
le temps
c'est la nappe à des partitions si
rigoureuse que puisse garder l'intégrité
dans le dans l'oeuvre dans le temps
comme la musique un apprentissage
d'emballer que ce soit comme le lac
l'apprentissage de la danse du ballet du
répertoire comme lac des cygnes aux
quelque chose de contemporain d'aucune
nouvelle création est une pratique
visuel oral entre danseurs et
chorégraphes et peut-être aujourd'hui
par led pro team hâtive du vidéo
finalement placé la chorégraphie est
soumis ou noirs deux corps du danseur
qui dans sa manière qui amène sa manière
de bouger d'interpréter donc soumis à
une forme de arm perfection je vous
voulez c'est donc avec un dernier
message
serez vous la trouvez dans ma danse que
j'ai co créé avec la danseuse échographe
daniela neubauer
or
oh
d
hu
et il
eh oui
nobody's perfect est oui finalement la
permission ne fait pas à l'art ni que la
créativité ni la vie comme la mienne
comme la vôtre
mais tant mieux c'est en étant un père
fait que peu fait de notre vie un chef
d'oeuvre
[Applaudissements]